The Conjuring 3 is chock full of easter eggs
from secret Annabelle and Nun connections
to classic horror movie tributes and clues
to the movie's big twists and reveals.
Yippee ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing all the things you
might have missed in The Devil Made Me Do
It and explaining how the movie connects to
the wider Conjuring universe.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
The creepy Annabelle doll is an iconic figure
in the Conjuring franchise and The Devil Made
Me Do It expands on the story behind the satanic
cult "Disciples of the Ram" from the first
Annabelle movie, where one of the its members,
Annabelle Higgins, murdered her adoptive parents,
before going on to attack Mia and John Form.
In the Conjuring 3, Ed and Lorraine meet Father
Kastner, a priest who investigated and exposed
"The Disciples of the Ram".
Kastner tells the Warrens they shouldn't underestimate
the power of these Satanists, and when Ed
asks him why someone would target an innocent
child...
"The "why" is irrelevant.
The "why" is counter to everything that the
Satanist stands for.
His sole aim is chaos."
...echoes what Detective Clarkin told the
Forms in Annabelle about what he'd learned
about the cult.
"That they did this to prove their devotion.
A sort of violence for violence's sake."
While researching the Disciples of the Ram,
Kastner collected various occult objects and
books, and kept them locked in his basement
room, similar to the Warrens' artefact room
where they keep the Annabelle doll and many
cursed and haunted objects from their investigations.
And his answer to Lorraine's suggestion that
he should burn all of it...
"I've thought of it.
But I felt it was safer to keep them locked.
I like taking guns off the streets."
...is similar to what Ed said in The Conjuring
when we were first introduced to the Warrens'
Artefact room.
"Why not just throw them in an incinerator?"
"Well, that would only destroy the vessel.
Sometimes it's better to keep the genie in
the bottle.
It's kind of like keeping guns off the street."
And there's another Conjuring easter egg in
The Devil Made Me Do It as the Perrons, the
family from the first movie's haunted house,
are name-dropped when the Warrens receive
some Get Well Soon flowers.
"Look what the Perron family sent.
Oh, that was sweet of them."
The demon nun Valak was the main antagonist
in The Conjuring 2 and although she didn't
make a direct appearance in the The Devil
Made Me Do It, after Arne's been possessed
there's a creepy little Nun figurine in his
bedroom at the boarding kennels.
Also in the movie's epilogue scenes is the
painting of the nun that came alive in the
second Conjuring movie and which has now been
moved into the Artefact room for safekeeping.
However, notice how the painting is kept framed
in the shot as Ed brings the Occultist's cursed
chalice into the room,
reminding us that Valak is still the principal
villain of the franchise and lurking in the
background,
just like Annabelle who is also carefully
framed in shot when the camera switches angles.
By the way, there was also another little
nod to The Conjuring 2, when Lorraine sees
an upside down cross while searching for the
Occultist's location, referencing the chilling
scene where Janet sees all the crosses in
a room slowly turn upside down.
A similar moment happens in the opening of
The Nun where a crucifix slowly inverts as
Valak emerges from the depths of the abbey,
and in the Conjuring Universe inverted crosses
are an demonic indicator, such as the one
that appears on Frenchie's neck in the Nun
and which the Warrens talk about during their
presentation about possession.
"And like that, an upside-down cross started
to appear from within his body."
Valak, of course, got her own evil backstory
in The Nun movie, and a connection with The
Conjuring 3 that you might not have noticed
is that one of the Occultist's victims, Jessica,
is played by actress Ingrid Bisu, who also
starred as Sister Oana in the demon nun's
origin story.
The fact these two characters are played by
the same actor could throw up some interesting
theories about the Conjuring Universe, especially
given that spoiler alert for the Nun, Sister
Oana was already dead in that movie.
Just before Arne murders Bruno, take a closer
look at the two posters on the wall behind
his landlord.
First of all, there's Black Sabbath's iconic
album cover featuring a mysterious – even
maybe witch-like – woman, a reference to
the Occultist who is manipulating Arne in
this very moment;
and then there's Ella Fitzgerald's Mack The
Knife, the famous song about a legendary criminal,
which foreshadows how Arne is about to pick
up a knife and become a notorious killer.
There are a number of books you can see behind
Ed and Lorraine in the office of Arne's defence
attorney, but one of particular relevance
is "Jonathan Strange & Mr Norrell" by Susanna
Clarke,
because the novel is set in an alternate history
of 19th-century England, much like how the
third Conjuring movie puts its own fictionalised
spin on real-life events, giving us an alternate
history of the Trial of Arne Johnson.
In The Conjuring 3, director Michael Chaves
wanted to pay homage to several iconic horror
movies.
So at the beginning of the film when Father
Gordon arrives in a cab at the Glatzel family
home, with a hat, coat and briefcase, the
mist and black silhouette figure that he forms
is a homage to the scene where Father Merrin
arrives in The Exorcist.
Other references to the iconic film include
how David wears speckled blue pyjamas during
the exorcism like Regan.
And how Arne sacrifices himself for David
by inviting the demon into his body, similar
to Father Karras in the The Exorcist, although
the outcome, of course, is different.
Chaves also says that the figure of Arne appearing
in a window as Father Gordon arrives is a
deliberate reference to Janet Leigh "seeing
Mother in the window" when she first arrives
at the Bates Motel in Psycho.
And the shot of David being showered with
blood inside the bathtub may also be a nod
to the iconic shower scene in that same film.
The waterbed scene in The Devil Made Me Do
It is also another deliberate tribute by the
director to one of the first horror movies
he ever saw, "A Nightmare on Elm Street 4:
The Dream Master".
So when David senses a face appearing to him
from inside the mattress, it's similar to
how Joey in Elm Street 4 sees a model appear
to him inside the bed.
And the hand bursting out of the mattress
to grab David is a nod to how Freddy Krueger
jumps out of the waterbed to attack Joey.
When Ed is possessed by the Occultist while
he's searching for Lorraine in the tunnels,
the shots of him holding a hammer and dragging
his injured leg along are a little hat-tip
to the showdown at the end of The Shining
where Jack Torrance limps along with an axe,
and is, like Ed, being influenced by an evil
entity.
There's an Annabelle easter egg via the name
of the Palmeri Funeral Home which Ed and Lorraine
visit to try and make a connection with the
Occultist through Jessica's dead body.
Palmeri was the name of the Pasadena apartment
complex that Mia and John moved to in the
first Annabelle.
"You're the new tenants at the Palmeri."
It's also the surname of Mary Ellen's crush
in Annabelle Comes Home, Bob Palmeri.
"Bob's-Got-Balls.
How you doing?"
There's also a visual shout out to Annabelle
Comes Home via the creepy colour wheel that
has been added to the Warrens' artefact room.
The wheel terrorised Judy Warren in that movie
when it manifested the many forms Annabelle
has taken in the Conjuring franchise.
"I like your dolls."
Although I prefer previous Conjuring villains
like Valak and Bathsheba, the Occultist has
some interesting paranormal powers such as
the ability to manipulate her victims from
afar and create optical illusions to trick
them into acts they wouldn't do.
She made Arne Johnson think his landlord was
some kind of hellish creature attacking him,
and also made Ed Warren momentarily think
Lorraine was an evil monster.
The Occultist had a copy of Lorraine appear
in front of her, mirroring her movements exactly.
This trippy moment was foreshadowed at the
beginning of the movie during David's exorcism
when the camera that Drew was filming with
was knocked over.
As the camera continued to film, it was pointed
towards a TV that was screening the live recording,
causing an image of the screen to replicate
itself endlessly.
This was a neat visual piece of foreshadowing
that was originally going to lead in to an
even more trippy sequence than we got in the
final movie.
In the trailers for the movie, you can see
a deleted scene where Lorraine sees many copies
of herself, replicating endlessly in a spiral
of sorts into the distance.
And if you want to learn more about that and
all the other deleted scenes including a cut
post-credits scene, I'll be talking about
all that in my next Conjuring video.
I'll add a link for you to watch it here and
in the video description as soon as it's ready.
So what did you think of the The Devil Made
Me Do It?
And how does it compare to your other favourite
movies in this franchise?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, leave a thumbs-up;
and a share is also hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full Conjuring Universe playlist
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!